what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest developments and demon slayer
story this is by far the most
unbelievable and crazy chapter we've
seen in a while so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you enjoy these Demon
Slayer reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer chat too
reviews obviously there will be spoilers
in this video I'm talking about the
latest demon slayer chapter chapter 199
after all you can bet chapter 200 is
also going to be a big chapter now
without further ado let's jump into it
as you'll remember the last chapter
finished off with the Sun rising it
looked like moves on all but eight guru
and tan judo and the rest of the Slayers
present we're doing their best to keep
moves on pinned to the wall this chapter
starts exactly where we left off with
the Sun peeking through distant
mountains this chapter is called
millennial dawn the chapter names used
to be focused on Mouzon who has lived
around 1,000 demon years and finally
after a millennium he's going to
experience the dawn as a demon right
away we see moves on in his shock and
scared face he's looking at the distant
Sun coming up and he knows he has to do
whatever he can to survive he unleashes
a huge explosion like attack that
completely destroys the surrounding area
suddenly is sent flying back eager to a
shot into a wall presumably meat so he
is sent flying to unlike the others she
seems to be down for the count right now
but she better survive this last chapter
we saw her get hit by Muslims attacked
but many Slayers got hit by his attacks
and it didn't seem that bad
so hopefully all's got on her part
she'll wake up safe and sound and
everything will be a-okay at least
that's my hope for best girl meet suti
tundra is the one who wit stands the
explosive attacks it holds on to his
sword which is doing a good job of
pinning moves onto the wall
despite all of his squirming however
some real crazy stuff happens Mulan's
attack ends up taking off Tundras left
arm we thought his one eye was bad
enough but now he's lost his arm too and
along with him so many others have lost
body parts like gu with his arm still
tons of being the determined boss that
he is keeps holding on with one hand
he keeps doing everything he can you
know how sooner pass out her die then
let moves on get away at this point I
have mad respect for him he's
practically unfazed by his lost arm as
often happens we are let into tons of
those thoughts he thinks to himself and
I quote make your blade turn red keep
your heart burning turn red please and
quote you can see he's in excruciating
pain and struggling hard by this point
but he's not giving up then just when he
needs it most
he gets support from Gill remember he
lost one arm and now Tundra lost one arm
so now they grip the sword together one
hand apiece team fricking work they're
making up for each other's weaknesses
and the memory of chojuro and then goku
is very much being channeled here time
joe told himself to keep his heart
burning in other words to not give up
hope when tundra and ghee you gripped
the sword together we see it in Goku's
flamed Suba on the sword as well he's
still inspiring tundra and the rest he's
still very much alive within there
burning hearts we get a shot of ghee you
and Tundra together which in my view
very much channels Gohan and Goku's
father son Kamehameha moment against
cell it's fitting too because Muslim is
also a big bad boss who's trying to
become the perfect life form try as he
might move on fails to unpin himself and
starts coughing out blood by now the Sun
is out enough for Milan's face to begin
to burn here it is boys
our Slayers have worked so hard and it
paid off the Sun is up and they managed
to keep moves on here long enough for it
to burn him this is the moment where
things really start to get crazy moves
on his thinking to himself just as
tundra was thinking a few moments ago he
thinks about shrinking his body but
decides against it since he would just
burn up in an instant he decides he will
use his flesh as armor to protect
himself then we get some al-qaeda type
transformation moves on starts growing
into a giant blob of flesh interestingly
enough he takes on the appearance of a
baby albeit a kind of gross vampire baby
people might have different opinions
about this but I think it works the
mangaka has been building up moves on
especially lately as a kind of pathetic
victim of fear rather than as an
invincible monster his greatest fear is
dying he can't face his own mortality
bravely like Mui Chino and then Goku did
Mulan is willing to do anything to just
stay alive and
that's what turned him into a monster
he's willing to break any rule and cross
any moral line in order to extend his
life that fear of death is what turned
him into a monster and continues to make
him monstrous metaphorically speaking
just like a baby may not want to leave
the safe and comfortable womb of its
mother to face the unknown moves on
fears facing the unknown of death and as
a result in effect he refers back to a
baby acting without principles just
trying to hold on to what's safe and
comfortable even though he's the big bad
boss of the series he's also just a big
baby who lives a life based on fear this
is why I think the choice that a pic
moves on in this way was actually
perfect do you notices that Mulan is
getting bigger and Tanner gets frickin
swallowed up by Milan's flesh again this
is very similar to ocula where Tetsuo
swallowed up his friend in this way - it
seems clear to me that the mangaka is
channeling both the ending of the cell
saga and especially the ending of the
al-qaeda movie these beyond cool
references suggest that we are in fact
reaching the end of demon slayer - or at
the very least the end of the moves on
saga giant baby moose answers crawling
with his flesh burning he's trying to
find shade before he burns into nothing
since he now has a lot of flesh that
gives him more time we see kiria clearly
worked up and worried kiria tells people
that they can't let Milan escape a bunch
of demons series from the high window of
a building drop a giant bookcase on
moose on hashtag knowledge is power
again the mangaka wants this to be a
team effort even the non Opie demon
Slayers can help slow moves on down in
their own way then we get a scene I
didn't think we'd see two demon Slayers
drive cars right in two moves on so they
two are helping without using crazy
breath Styles red blades or demon marks
Mulan destroys one car with his fist
giving us a sense of how big he is right
now other demon Slayers go on to block
his way with train cars one Demon Slayer
member thinks to himself that they have
to stand firm since the pillars can't
fight anymore I really love how all of
these guys have managed to contribute to
the fight everyone has a role to play
and although these guys may not be as
strong they are brave willingly risking
their lives to help in any way they can
Korea begins
cry telling them to fall back because
Mulan is about to kill them but they
don't they want to slow down moves on as
much as possible
even if it means death mad respect for
these guys luckily for them the pillars
are not done yet sana me cuts off the
arm moves on was gonna use to hit the
demon slayer members summon me himself
is exhausted but moves on keeps freaking
going
he starts climbing over to train car but
then a chain appears around wools ons
neck and pulls him back
it is Guillaume a of course he's made a
reappearance and demon slayer core
members are helping him pull Mose on
back they succeed and Mulan falls
backwards as he continues to burn in the
sunlight kiri is begging for him to
disintegrate already and his sister's
praying to whoever she can to her dad
mom sister and God and this makes sense
because they need all the help they can
get
moves on just won't give up and he
starts digging into the ground
hoping to hide from the Sun that way at
this point we have at least eight more
demons their core members lending their
strength and helping yo made to hold
moves on back view uses the 10th form of
water breathing constant flux to attack
moves on just as that Aegis attack took
the form of lightning dragon and Tundras
took the form of fire dragon gives
attack takes the form of a water dragon
although he's weaker with one hand he
sunna me and even eager to do everything
they can to weaken moves on keep in mind
the poison cocktail that Tomeo gave two
moves on is still at work he's in the
sunlight and he has a lot of accumulated
damage every little hit is magnified
because of how bad moves on is doing
every little bit counts
any attack now can be the straw that
broke the camel's back we're told
everyone is at their limit doing their
all Joel Mays chain begins to break keep
in mind this is a huge deal
not even the insanely powerful upper
moon one kokeshi bow could do anything
to this chain because of how strong the
material is and here we have people
pushing themselves so hard that it
frickin broke Mouzon has his face well
into the ground at this point but then
we get a glimpse of Tundras hand and
sword inside massan's flesh as we'll
talk it out it doesn't kill him he's
alive within the huge blob of flesh I
think we all expected that which is why
I didn't freak out or assume he was dead
when he initially got absorbed then from
his position he does what the other
couldn't he gets a huge cut around moves
on space causing him to raise his head
in pain the Sun hits him and he begins
significantly disintegrating he just
looks like a crying distressed baby
which again I don't think is a
coincidence and that is the end of this
chapter everyone has been going beyond
plus ultra here they're all at their
limits but they just threw everything
they could have moves on and it appears
to have paid off we're going to get a
chapter next week and boy am i height it
looks like it's over but the mangaka
purposely didn't have moves on disappear
into nothing yet she still wants to
build suspense but I don't see a way out
of this four moves on right now let me
know if you do in the comments so glad
to see that Eagle is alive and although
we're kind of being asked to worry about
meet suti right now I think she'll be ok
they just didn't make enough of a big
deal of it when she actually got
attacked for me to think that it was a
fatal move we still need to see Nez Zuko
we need to see what's gonna happen
between Tangier and canal and so on this
could potentially wrap up next chapter
with the winding down conclusion we'll
have to wait and see but let me know
your predictions and thoughts in the
comments it seems like it would be
difficult for the series to continue
with new bad guys when so many of our
star players are badly injured and
missing so many body parts we could
definitely be seeing a full metal
alchemist like ending next chapter where
the demon Slayers put down their swords
and return to normal life but with a
newfound appreciation for it anyways
that is it for this video we add insane
moments I didn't expect to see like
giant baby moves on Tundra losing his
arm
Akeno moments and books being used to
hurt moves on truly an eventful chapter
and after all this time after a
millennium moves on has experienced the
dawn and hes disintegrating everyone
seemingly gotten their revenge and your
teaches life purpose has come to
fruition
he has albeit indirectly led to the fall
of Musa if next chapter is a happy
ending we can say that these characters
definitely deserved it if you enjoyed
this review make sure to smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss the next demon slayer chapter
review which could just be the very last
one after all it's the big 200th chapter
so it wouldn't be so
if the mangaka chose that important
milestone to end it on a special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive YouTube issues and
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank our the one to your patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans Stephen
Ingrid ah hello Lana attempt the world
stealers the school bus Tyson Kirino
acquire respect Patti - and Chris Loki
and I can't forget our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Odin
Anatole Cassatt Suki alpha do angel Cruz
team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
Finney dolla beat Ted no Ted Joel - Joel
Stanton very Gucci Jessica Calif on
Alicia actor Emperor otaku and jccc
wocka thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com slash anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name feature in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
a private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse app or more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see us space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]